hey guys it's max max tech we just got
in the new 16 inch MacBook Pro and today
we're gonna be comparing it to the
previous 15 inch model we're going to
look at all of the things that have
changed we're gonna look at the new
keyboards the new speakers the
microphones the size and weight of the
macbook pro and we're even gonna take
off the back panels so we can take a
look at the new fan design and also with
the new batteries and see any other
changes that they may have made so let's
start off here with a box isn't the
first thing that popped out of me and
when I pulled it out of the cardboard
box is the size and weight of the new 16
inch here we have the 15 inch you guys
could tell that there's extra space on
the side on the top it's definitely
heavier and then if we look at the
actual design Apple change it after many
years of having the previous one to this
big colorful look so we could actually
see the beautiful 16 inch display so
let's go ahead and open it up the lid is
super tight let's get the Mac out of
here I'm going to take the plastic
wrapping off and I'm actually gonna set
this aside interesting okay and let's
take a look at the charger so Apple did
up the wattage from 87 watts now to 96
watts this is instead of plastic it's
like a wax paper let's grab the previous
charger out and they are basically the
same I don't think there's any size
difference maybe just more efficient on
the inside 87 watts 96 watts so the new
16 inch MacBook Pros did get heavier
about a third of a pound and yes I can
tell the difference but I have owned one
of these the 15 inches ever since they
came out so I have a lot of use with
them let's stack these on top of each
other see if it's any longer and yes it
is both wider and longer and as far as
thickness it's hard to tell in the hand
but if we put them side-by-side yes the
new 16 inch is thicker now let's go
ahead and open these up and compare the
displays Apple went from a 15 point 4
inch display to a 16 inch display and
yes you can tell that the new one is
larger even if you're just using this
one not only is the screen larger the
bezels also shrunk as well the four had
slightly smaller the side bezels are
thinner and that definitely makes it
look nicer now the color accuracy and
brightness of this
place have not changed they're both p3
500 nits but the resolution has been
bumped up just a bit to compensate for
the larger size now one thing that has
changed is that with the new 60 inch
backward Pro we can actually change the
display refresh rate to match up better
with either 24 or 25 frames per second
video and if you change it to say forty
seven point zero point nine five Hertz
that could potentially save you a little
bit of battery life taking a look below
the displays we could tell that the
speaker grills on the 16 inch are
slightly wider to compensate and then
the first thing that jumps out to me is
that the touch ID sensor is now separate
not built into the touch bar now on the
left hand side we now have a physical
Escape key as well a lot of people ask
for that now looking at the keyboard I
can right away tell a couple of things
well first off the key caps themselves
are raised higher up from the actual
little indentation little cut out from
the aluminum and this little cut out is
deeper to compensate for the taller keys
themselves now along with that the key
caps themselves are actually slightly
smaller so there's a bit more room
between them compared to the butterfly
keyboard and looking at the bottom right
we can see that the arrow keys are now
back to the old way where we have this t
configuration so it's awesome to see
that Apple is listening to its users now
let's actually feel the keyboard now I'm
use of the butterfly keys I've used
these ever since actually 2015 with the
12-inch Retina MacBook very low travel
almost nothing but they are pretty
stable the new ones actually go back to
the previous design where we're not
using butterfly keys we're using scissor
switches and the difference is
absolutely noticeable I don't have a
document open here but the travel is
about double what we have with the
butterfly keys and now time for
something that I am very excited about
and that is our speaker comparison now
for I don't even know how many years
we've just had two speakers in the
MacBook Pro nobody asked for better
speakers because they were already great
better than any Windows laptop I heard
especially in this form factor but Apple
took it to a whole nother level we now
six speakers including two woofers built
in so we're gonna test this out with a
number of ways usually we just play a
song which we're gonna do but then we're
also gonna
some Atmos test for surround sound and
then it's some low-end based test so
make sure you guys stick around to hear
that let's start it out now I'm not
gonna lie I do wish that the new one was
at least as loud as the previous one was
before but one thing we noticed is
there's definitely a lot more separation
between the different frequencies the
new macro has a six speaker so it can
separate the high frequencies the mids
and then the low end where the previous
one it has to blend all that together
with two speakers even though it did a
great job we definitely hear a lot more
separation a lot more I guess clarity in
the mids and even in the bass it
actually sounds a lot like it's much
deeper kind of comparing maybe a cell
phone to a tablet you have a bigger
drivers and it definitely sounds better
and then in the vocals they definitely
sound cleaner as well not sure if you
guys can hear it through this microphone
but let me know what you thought so now
I have the surround test running we have
two speakers versus six and here there's
definitely some kind of I don't know if
it's fake surround or what but some
simulation as the helicopter just flew
kind of over my shoulder but the volume
is quite a bit lower than that previous
track so let's switch over to this one
so with the surround-sound test I could
definitely tell that the new MacBook Pro
is more immersive maybe because of the
speakers are the added base but it is
doing a better job so that's great for
movies now another thing that's very
interesting is that with this test the
new MacBook Pro actually sounds louder
than the old one alright guys so we just
listened to a frequency sweep hear a
couple different videos and some other
base tests and it's very interesting the
new MacBook Pro can go all the way down
to 30 Hertz where you can hear it
whereas the 15-inch model it goes down
to 45 Hertz so we definitely have a
deeper base here we listen to a couple
different tracks as well with a lot of
bass and you definitely can tell the
separation between the base and the
other frequencies much better than the
previous one all right guys now it's
time to test out the webcam and the
microphone this is the quality from the
15.4 inch MacBook Pro and this is the
webcam quality with the new 16 inch
MacBook Pro along with the new
microphone setup that Apple is calling
studio quality microphones you let me
know if you think it's good enough to
replace a dedicated microphone down in
the comment section below now let's go
ahead and open these guys up and take a
look at the internals the first thing
that really jumps out at me is that the
fans are now made out of metal either
just the center or maybe the whole fan
altogether compared to plastic over here
and the new 16 inch MacBook Pro has
thicker fans so all of this whole
assembly where the air goes through is
actually you've raised up higher now the
other thing that really stands out these
batteries they are now thicker all
around and then the ones on the side are
actually longer because we have more
space in this chassis and that's what's
making this battery be 100 watt hours
instead of about 83 watt hours and 100
watt hours is actually the maximum that
you can legally have on an airplane now
the other thing we see is with the old
15-inch MacBook Pro we have all this
empty space over here on the sides
this whole speaker assembly is much
smaller here it's actually longer and
making use of that extra space now these
new fans definitely make a difference as
far as performance and heat we actually
made a separate video where we took a
look at a bunch of different benchmarks
both for the CPU and the graphics and we
tested out thermal throttling so if you
guys want to see that video we're gonna
have it at the end of this one
definitely don't miss out on
that the actual CPUs inside of these
machines are identical to the ones that
came out earlier this year the base has
a 2.6 keager it's six core and then the
higher-end models are eight cores and
the graphics cards those have been
updated and there's been some pretty
great improvements which you guys
definitely want to check out in that
dedicated video now the other thing that
changed is the base amount of SSD for a
long time we had 256 gigs of SSD base
Apple has now bumped that up up to 512
so that saves you $200 right there and
then the maximum went from 4 terabytes
up to 8 and that is absolutely crazy to
have that much storage in such a tiny
lightweight machine
so overall Apple made a ton of changes
to this new machine that's probably the
biggest jump we've had since 2016 or
maybe even before that we have a lot of
improvements some that we asked for such
as keyboards smaller bezels and other
things that we didn't ask for such as
the speakers and I think that a lot of
people are very happy with this new 16
inch MacBook Pro now we're gonna have
other videos coming out we're gonna do a
gaming video we're gonna get the new 8
core model with the best graphics I was
just starting the ship next week so make
sure you guys subscribe using a little
circle above and enable notifications
down below and definitely go and check
out our benchmark and thermal video
right over there this is the maxim ax
Tech and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]